♪ ♪
>> Sean: ALSO DEVELOPING
TONIGHT IN THE WASHINGTON SEWER
AND SWAMP, DEMOCRATS CONTINUE TO
TRY AND RAN THROUGH THEIR FAR
LEFT SOCIALIST $3.5 TRILLION
WISHLIST, BUT GET THIS,
DEMOCRATS INFIGHTING, SHOWING NO
SIGNS OF SLOWING DOWN, TWO
SENATORS SAY THEY ARE NOT ON
BOARD WITH THE MULTITRILLION
DOLLAR RECONCILIATION PACKAGE
WHILE SENATOR SANDERS IS NOW
SUGGESTING THAT HE'S A NO
VOTE ON THE INFRASTRUCTURE DEALS
NOT ACCOMPANIED BY THE
RECONCILIATION PACKAGE AND JUST
WANTS -- WHAT DO THEY WANT HERE?
$3.5 TRILLION ON TOP OF ALL OF
THE MONEY THEY'VE ALREADY SPENT,
THREE COMMUNITY COLLEGE FOR
ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS, MORE
GREEN NEW DEAL SPECIAL INTEREST
GIVEAWAYS, ELECTRIC THIS,
ELECTRIC THAT, UNIVERSAL PRE-K,
CORPORATE CAPITAL GAINS, TAX CUT
HIKE -- TAX HIKES, YOU WILL PAY
FOR THAT.
GOVERNMENT-FUNDED CHILD CARE,
GREAT.
THEY ALREADY MESS OUR KIDS UP IN
PUBLIC SCHOOLS SO MANY PLACES,
NOW WE'RE GOING TO INDOCTRINATE
THEM MORE.
MORE PAID LEAD, EXTENDING
OBAMACARE, A MAJOR BOOST TO IRIS
FUNDING SO ALL OF US CAN BE
AUDITED EVERY YEAR, NOT JUST ME,
BIDEN IS STILL BIZARRELY TRYING
TO CLAIM THAT RECKLESS SPENDING
PLANS ACTUALLY COST "$0."
OKAY, JOE, SOUNDS LIKE YOU'RE
USING THE OLD-STYLE ABACUS THAT
YOU WERE TRAINED ON.
WE ACTUALLY TODAY HAVE SOMETHING
CALLED A CALCULATOR.
SIMPLE MATH, JOE.
YOU DON'T NEED TO GO TO MIT TO
FIGURE IT OUT.
ANYWAY, MEANWHILE BIDEN
CONTINUES TO RELY ON
BARACK OBAMA TO SELL HIS
DESTRUCTIVE AGENDA WHO TOLD ABC
THE COUNTRY DESPERATELY NEEDS
THE TRILLIONS AND TRILLIONS IN
NEW SPENDING.
HERE WITH REACTION, AUTHOR OF A
BRAND-NEW BOOK FOR SUCH A TIME
AS THIS, OUTNUMBERED COHOST
KAYLEIGH McENANY AS WELL AS
FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR JOE CONCHA.
I DON'T KNOW, I LOOK AT THE
TRILLIONS OF DOLLARS, JOE, AND
YOU KNOW WHAT I SEE?
-- YOU SHOULD HAVE YOUR OWN
SHOW ON MEDIA.
>> I'VE HEARD.
>> Sean: I SEE THE NEW GREEN
GREEN DEAL RADICALS RUNNING THE
PARTY AND THEY ARE EVEN TELLING
NANCY PELOSI NOPE, SHE WANTED TO
VOTE IN THE INFRASTRUCTURE BILL,
THEY SAID NO DEAL.
SO NOW THE WHOLE PARTY IS IN
DISARRAY AND WHO KNOWS WHAT
JOE MANCHIN AND KYRSTEN SINEMA
WILL DO IN THE SENATE.
>> THAT'S THE THING, IF THIS
THING FAILS, IT WILL BE
DEMOCRATS THAT ULTIMATELY PUT IT
IN THE GROUND, SEAN, AND
SPENDING BILLIONS FOR PROGRAMS
LIKE TREE EQUITY, THAT'S
BILLIONS WITH A B AND PROVIDING
FREE COLLEGE FOR THOSE HERE
ILLEGALLY IN THIS COUNTRY.
YOU LOOK AT THE COMMITTEE FOR
RESPONSIBLE FEDERAL BUDGET AND
THEY LOOK AT THE NUMBERS WITHOUT
SPAIN AND THEY SAY THIS
$3.5 TRILLION BILL WOULD CALL
FOR THE U.S. GOVERNMENT TO
BORROW $1 TRILLION, THEY ALSO
SAY IT WOULD ADD 3 TRILLION
ADDED TO THE NATIONAL DEBT OVER
TEN YEARS.
THAT'S BACKBREAKING STUFF AND
THEY ALSO SAY THE PRICE TAG IS
REALLY ACTUALLY 5.5 JOIN --
>> Sean: JOE, WAIT A MINUTE.
THEY SAID THAT THIS ISN'T GOING
TO COST US A PENNY, WON'T COST
US 1 CENT.
>> HENCE MY POINT, RIGHT?
THIS IS GOING TO COST US A LOT.
EVEN "THE WASHINGTON POST"
FACT-CHECKER CALLED THE $0 CLAIM
"MYTHICAL ZERO" AND SAID THAT
THE PRESIDENT, WHOEVER WRITES
MR. BIDEN'S SCRIPT, BEING
MISLEADING AND THIS SORT OF
MESSAGING, IT'S GOING TO PUT
THIS BILL AT SERIOUS RISK
BECAUSE IN THE COURT OF PUBLIC
OPINION THIS IS GETTING LEFT OUT
OF THE ROOM.
EITHER WAY, TO YOUR POINT, THIS
BILL IS EITHER TANKED BY
"THE SQUAD," AOC WING OF THE
PARTY WHO PROMISED TO TANK IT
WAS SO CALLED HUMAN
INFRASTRUCTURE BUILT --
MODERATES, RIGHT.
JOE MANCHIN AND KYRSTEN SINEMA,
IT ONLY TAKES ONE.
IT'S HARD TO SEE HOW THIS BILL
BECOMES REALITY, AND THE IRONY
IS AGAIN, DEMOCRATS WILL ONLY
HELP THEMSELVES TO BLAME IN A
CIVIL WAR THAT IS ONLY GETTING
WORSE.
>> Sean: OKAY, SO NOW THE
QUESTION REPUBLICANS ARE TO DO.
DONALD TRUMP GAVE THE REPUBLIC
AND PARTY, LET'S BE HONEST, A
SHOT OF ADRENALINE, A SPINE, A
BACKBONE, AND HE SHOW PEOPLE HOW
TO FIGHT, AND YOU KNOW WHAT,
IT'S NOT BEEN BALL, RIGHT?
IT'S A BLOOD SPORT, AS THEY CALL
IT IN WASHINGTON, SO MY QUESTION
IS, REPUBLICANS NOW, THEY ARE
OUT OF THE PROCESS, THEY ARE NOT
BEING INCLUDED AT ALL.
DEMOCRATS NOW ARE FACING A DEBT
CEILING PROBLEM.
THEY HAVE CONTROL OF THE HOUSE,
THE SENATE, AND THE WHITE HOUSE.
SO I DON'T THINK ANY REPUBLICANS
SHOULD LIFT A FINGER TO HELP
THEM RAISE THE DEBT LIMIT SO
THEY CAN WASTE ALL THAT MONEY
THAT THEY SAY IS FREE.
>> SEAN, YOU'RE EXACTLY RIGHT.
BUT HERE'S THE REALITY THAT WE
ALL KNOW.
YOU WILL HAVE NANCY PELOSI,
CHUCK SCHUMER, JOE BIDEN, TRYING
TO BLAME A LACK OF RAISING THE
DEBT CEILING OR THE SHUTTING
DOWN OF THE GOVERNMENT ON
REPUBLICANS.
IT IS NONSENSICAL, IT WOULD BE
CONFOUNDING, BECAUSE GUESS WHO
RUNS BOTH BRANCHES, THE HOUSE,
THE SENATE, THE LEGISLATIVE
BRANCH AND THE EXECUTIVE BRANCH?
IT'S DEMOCRATS.
BUT THEY ARE ALREADY TRYING TO
BLAME THIS ON REPUBLICANS, SO
REPUBLICANS COME INTO YOUR
POINT, SEAN, NEED TO HAVE A
SPINE, NEED TO STAND UP, SAY
THIS IS CATEGORICALLY ON
DEMOCRATS.
IF THIS DOESN'T PASS IT'S
BECAUSE OF EITHER AOC AND
RASHIDA TLAIB, OR, YOU KNOW, THE
FAR LEFT FLANK, OR IT'S BECAUSE
OF KYRSTEN SINEMA AND MANCHIN
TAKING IT.
ONE OF THE TWO DEMOCRATS, IT IS
CATEGORICALLY NOT REPUBLICANS.
THEY WILL TRY TO BLAME IT
HOWEVER ON THE RIGHT AS THEY
ALWAYS DO.
>> Sean: LET'S PLAY A LITTLE
JOHN MCLACHLAN, PREDICTIONS.
DOES IT PASS?
JOE CONCHA.
>> IT DOES NOT PASS WHATSOEVER.
BYE-BYE!
>> WOW!
GOT TO DISAGREE!
I'VE GOT TO SAY, DEMOCRATS
ALWAYS STICK TOGETHER, THEY DO,
SO THEY DO HAVE THAT ONE
ATTRIBUTE.
I THINK IT WILL PASS.
>> Sean: ELEANOR CLIFT, NEXT.
ALL RIGHT, WE'RE DONE.
>> THANK YOU [INDISCERNIBLE].
>> Sean: EXACTLY COME EJECT
YOUR MIND.
NOW WE ARE REALLY